representan los siguientes datos usando
un diagrama de carga excluye la mediana
cuando calculas los cuartiles ok veamos
si podemos resolver esto y tenemos aquí
un montón de datos y después dice si te
sirve de algo puedes arrastrar los
números y colocarlos en un orden
distinto el orden no afecta a la
respuesta y te encargo que hagas lo
mismo porque la mejor forma de aprender
es practicar y en la canaca de min
tenemos 150.000 ejercicios para ti que
puedes utilizar para practicar así que
regresemos a resolver este problema
vamos a empezar ordenando estos datos
para que se pueda ver nuestro rango así
que el menor de ellos si te das cuenta
es este 2 lo voy a poner justo aquí
después tengo a este 4 lo voy a poner
hasta acá no tengo 5 pero si un par de 6
es estaba para acá y este por acá 7 8 y
por acá tengo otro 8 y de hecho acá
tengo otro tenemos un montón de ochos
después tengo un 9
es el último de ellos así que ya están
ordenados y si te das cuenta mi número
menor es 2 entonces es por esta razón
que los bigotes son útiles nos ayudan a
visualizar el rango entero lo voy a
poner aquí en 2000 número menor es 2 y
bueno el número mayor es 12 por lo tanto
voy a poner este bigote aquí en el 12 y
con esto ya sabemos el rango y ahora
vamos a calcular la mediana lo cual nos
va a ayudar para poder colocar esta
línea central que tenemos aquí y también
nos va a ayudar a encontrar en donde
colocar estas otras dos líneas que
tenemos aquí es decir estas dos
fronteras las cuales nos van a delimitar
la caja es decir las dos líneas que
definirán las medianas que dividen en
cuartos a nuestros datos o las medianas
de los dos cuarteles o cercanos a las
medianas de los dos cuarteles
dependiendo de cuántos números tengamos
sin embargo esta línea de en medio nos
va a decir cuál es la mediana de todo el
conjunto de datos que tenemos
la mediana es solo el número de en medio
de estos que tenemos ya ordenados y si
te das cuenta la mediana va a ser este
número 8 que tenemos aquí de estos 11
números que tenemos aquí es este 8
porque va a ser aquel que tiene 5 datos
de cada lado si tuviéramos 10 datos aquí
o un número par de datos
en ese caso tendremos 2 números
centrales es decir tendremos 2 números
en medio y entonces para encontrar la
mediana tendríamos que tomar la media de
esos dos datos centrales y bueno si esto
te parece un poco confuso sería muy
bueno que pierda los videos de khan
academy sobre mediana en ellos se habla
con más detalle y claridad sobre cómo
encontrarla pero bueno aquí tengo 11
datos por lo que mi mediana es este 8
que tenemos aquí pues él tiene 5 datos
de la izquierda 1 2 3 4 y 5 y tiene 5
datos a la derecha 1 2 3 4 y 5 y es más
si tuviera mi lápiz de la tableta de
notas lo circularía en este momento
y entonces es por eso que la línea del
medio tiene que estar justo arriba del
valor de 8 justo aquí y ahora tenemos
que buscar que datome es la mediana de
esta mitad inferior que tenemos aquí y
nos dicen excluye la mediana cuando
calculas los cuartiles así que como esta
es la mediana entonces vamos a ignorarla
y solo vamos a fijarnos en los números
anteriores a ella en estos cinco datos
que tenemos aquí y bueno
cuál es la mediana de sus cinco datos la
mediana es el dato de en medio que en
este caso es este 6 que tenemos aquí así
que el inicio de nuestro segundo cuartil
va a ser ese 6 que tenemos ahí este de
aquí por lo tanto aquí va a quedar mi
frontera izquierda y lo mismo para el
tercer cuarto recuerda que esta era mi
mediana original la mediana de todos los
datos y por lo tanto vamos a ignorarla y
solamente nos fijamos en la mitad
superior de los números en esta mitad
superior de los números dime cuál es el
valor que está en medio
bueno tenemos 5 datos aquí ordenados y
el que está en medio es justo este 9 de
aquí es decir la mediana de la mitad
superior y ese va a ser el fin de mi
segundo cuartil 9 y lo voy a poner aquí
así de simple
lo logramos hemos construido ya nuestro
diagrama de cajas y bigotes